are we witnessing the birth of a new art
form
right now there are machine learning
tools being created by an open source
community that hold the possible
potential to allow you to visualize
anything you want as long as you provide
the imagination Direction and the
training data but image-based machine
learning has some limitations and one of
its biggest limitations is consistency
over time we tried to solve that problem
with an experiment that we called anime
rock paper scissors I chose you to rock
cross blades and due to our use of AI in
that project it ended up becoming one of
the most controversial things we've ever
done
now we're doing it again why well I'm
glad you asked
my people on this day the one year
anniversary of my coronation I bring
forth a token of peace all right so
first things first I have a huge
announcement after months of hard work
we have finished anime rock paper
scissors too and it is live right now on
Corridor digital.com you can watch it
right now when this video dropped on
YouTube that video dropped on the
website so once you're done watching
this video go check it out alright let's
get into this so how are we going to
make episode 2 any better well before I
explain how we first need to talk about
why this is such a big deal for us come
here I want to talk to you
okay Sam and I started making videos
over 20 years ago when visual effects
software had just become accessible on
our home computers which were iMacs at
the time this was completely impossible
a few years before when these tools were
only accessible to Hollywood Studios and
as technology marched forwards we got
our first digital cameras we got our
first non-linear editors and our first
3D animation programs and eventually we
made our first movie imagine if you
approached me with a new piece of
experimental software something so
Advanced that I could take normal
footage from any camera and visualize
anything I wanted that is the Holy Grail
of visual effects that is the ultimate
ideal goal of the software that we use
to visualize impossible things to build
worlds and images that don't exist in
reality and last year a form of machine
learning for images called latent
diffusion was released open source to
the public since then it's been
implemented all over the place it's in
Photoshop it's in Microsoft sping
there's even an open source model
released to the community from stability
AI when we discovered a way to train our
own characters and images into this
process it opened up a huge world for us
creatively that Holy Grail of VFX
appeared to be in our hands however we
quickly discovered that while this tool
is incredibly powerful for still images
it doesn't work for video
any attempt to filter a moving image
through this process just ended up with
a flickering distorted mess so we
thought if he brought some of our visual
effects skills to the table here we
might be able to solve some of these
problems that's why we made anime rock
paper scissors so one of the main points
of controversy with the first rock paper
scissors was that we had trained the
style on a pre-existing anime named a
Vampire Hunter D bloodlust which is a
great movie you should go check it out
but with rock paper scissors too it was
important to us to figure out how to
train in our own art style from our own
art that we create from scratch so
that's one of the things we set out to
do with this project
this is the script for anime rock paper
scissors too the first one had about 80
shots this one has almost 400 so the
first thing we need to do is come up
with a pipeline using software that's
never been used in a pipeline before and
figure out a way to efficiently get
through 400 shots compared to the 80
that we did before secondly you see how
thick the script is we have so many
different environments the first rock
paper scissors had one environment and
it was like a flat floor and two
characters standing and talking to each
other now we're all over the place and
it's much more complicated
next up we need to eliminate that
flicker we need to get better at that
emotions are what matter we need to be
able to read the expressions in the
characters faces see the eyes the
windows to their soul so we got to get
that flicker fixed next up
we need to develop our own art style
from scratch we want this to feel like
our very own anime meaning we need to
invent our very own style for what the
characters are going to look like
finally we still need to do a whole
bunch of actual hand animation because
we only effectively get a filtered
character from a computer we still need
to put them on a background give them
motion give the camera motion do the
lines the blurs do the light rays the
blows and add all these other elements
to the shots that need them a lot of
which are just animated by hand
I want to show you the process of how we
made rock paper scissors too but first
let's talk about the controversy so why
was the first rock paper scissors so
controversial and why are we making a
second one
well a tool like stable diffusion offers
a lot of power when creating images and
things that were previously quite
difficult have become a lot easier
now there's a lot of discussion around
AI being transformative versus
derivative
and when we made the first rock paper
scissors a lot of these conversations
were brought to the Forefront so I don't
want to speak for anyone else's
Viewpoint here all I can really offer is
my experience as an artist using these
tools if you are someone who's concerned
about AI in the Art Space well
I invite you to come along as I show you
how we use it in the creation of a scene
for rock paper scissors too and I'll let
you decide if our work connects with you
I will offer one opinion if you would be
so kind as to indulge me I think good
art at least it's an emotional reaction
regardless of what tools and or
techniques are used and that emotional
connection is different for every single
person so at the end of the day all we
can do is offer what we create and the
rest is up to you
all right well without further Ado let's
take a look at how we made a scene from
anime rock paper scissors too
every good video starts with a good idea
but then it's followed by a lot of work
put into the script Sam and I bounce
pages off each other back and forth
until we're locked in with what we want
and it's time you'll record The Voice
lines then we record all the lines of
dialogue in the script like this one
Jewels do my eyes betray me
so we plan out the shop by writing text
down in edit this tells us what each
shot is going to be this is simpler than
having to draw a storyboard for every
shot and see exactly how long it needs
to be
so now it's off to designing our
costumes and then acting out the scenes
on a green screen while trying to pair
them with Dynamic inventive
cinematography
so now we have our characters filmed
it's time to create the art style that
we're going to use and for that we go to
my friend Josh Newland hi Josh so I
reached out to you to join us for this
project because we wanted to create an
art style specific to this project I'm
the artist that provided the line work
that will inform the characters the
things that I tended to exaggerate were
cheekbones chins you got angular
features that looked like a great cheese
on them obviously exaggerated eyes I'm
not traditionally an anime artist so
studying everything from Bang by Hunter
D to dundum uh Cowboy Bebop and then
trying to somehow blend that with a
cartoonier style that I tend to do
um so Batman studies of like eye after
eye after eye meant drawing uh random
villagers soldiers your characters from
like every conceivable angle with varied
emotions
and then getting feedback from
so now that we have the art style from
Josh we take photos of our actor wearing
the costume we take the art from Josh
and we feed that into a generalized
diffusion model which changes it it
makes a fine tune and it replicates our
character in our art style the reason we
do this is because by making a model
only capable of recreating one character
in one art style we eliminate one of the
biggest sources of flickering because
the diffusion process has a tendency to
interpret an image differently every
time it runs due to that randomization
we can effectively force it to only look
at things one way our way so now we have
our foreground character
we still need our background so our
backgrounds start as 3D renders I love
Unreal Engine it's really cool it's free
I love creating environments in it which
is why it's perfect for this we have a
big environment what do we do well we
compose things like we shape the
environment and then above all we do the
actual camera work we actually
put down as you see here lots of little
cameras that match up with every single
plate and from there it's actually a
really simple process to get them out of
unreal and process them with stable
diffusion the image is given a style
transfer not a specific artist or
anything but just generally the medium
style the setting so at this point our
use of AI is complete but we still have
a lot of work to do before we actually
have a finished shot
now we need to take our foreground and
we take our background elements and put
them together while also animating them
against each other while also adding any
other animated elements that we want to
have in there as well as lighting
elements and other cool effects and all
that good stuff this is one of the most
time consuming parts of our work but
also some of the most fulfilling because
we're sitting down just adding our touch
to every single moment of the story so
once that's done we repeat that process
for every single shot until we have a
seam like this one
[Music]
oh father's grave he taught me
everything but now that I stand here I'm
filled with questions
father I need your wisdom I have never
questioned your love for me but I begin
to question the love of our creator
Faith force is my hand to lose every
battle
myself yet wait if you really dare guide
me and I will follow
[Music]
thank you
if I must be a king to challenge him
then so be it I shall not see him again
until I wear a crown of my own
I must find a kingdom in need of a king
oh wow that's cool obviously the first
thing that comes to mind is just the
stability of it the the lack of flick I
mean I remember as good as we could get
it in the first episode it was still
noticeable I'm not sure what's different
under the hood there it's notably better
I am also noticing the aesthetic change
like the style is different yeah it's
kind of crazy considering you can stop
on almost any frame and it's cohesive
and consistent and the other one you
stop on any frame and you see The Ghost
and you see all the other little
elements so RPS one does look a little
bit more just like rotoscope foot it
looks like just a filter applied on top
of video whereas the second one looks a
little bit more like it was actually a
cartoon we're not trying to replace
anything here we're trying to come up
with something new I find these visuals
super intriguing and I haven't been this
jazzed about visual effects since we
started our YouTube channel 14 years ago
and never thought I would be able to
make something that looks like this
because I'm not a traditional animator
but here we are with a full episode of
an anime made with six people over four
months nothing close to a studio budget
and it's live on Corridor digital.com
and go check it out right now it's only
possible for this to exist because of
the subscribers on our website so thank
you so much to all of our subscribers if
you're considering subscribing well you
got a great reason too right now and
we're going to follow this up with a
whole bunch of tutorials teaching people
this method and how we did it and all
that kind of stuff over on quarter
digital so I'll see you guys there thank
you so much for watching the video